episode 10 ends on a brilliant
cliffhanger set up for a season two
so they're offering a ton of money and
full relocation services get this
for all of us
to move
to beautiful
where the heck are the garcias going
next
i would tell you if i knew
um
but i don't
every i'm looking at you where are the
garcias moving uh you might want to look
at another jeff that's in the room for
that
[Laughter]
is he here can you pull him in we want
some my lips are sealed
you cannot torture me and get it out of
me
my
wow so you're really now jeff knows and
has an idea does the cast know they do
not they do not nobody knows except me
so jeffrey you went in and you read that
line and and you delivered it but you
have no idea where the show's going next
he has no idea wow i have some ideas
on valley are we going to texas exactly
every part of mexico truly a cliffhanger
i just spoke with jeff your uh your ep
and he said not a soul knows but he
knows not even his wife knows oh no no
it's a it's a thing it's a thing like
it's a thing are you pestering him do
you have ideas of course girl of course
we're pestering him everybody is
pestering but we are
we are fingers crossed for season two
and listen there are worse places to
film and we will just have to see we are
just as much uh out of the loop on that
as the audience will be when they're
watching it maybe you know more than us
where would you like to see your
character go in season two for my
character i feel like this season one
was really like getting close to the
family and spending this time with them
so i would love to see her like explore
that
comfortableness and just get goofy and
whatnot
definitely more experiencing and seeing
more family stuff and then also seeing
her start to follow her dreams and stuff
like that and i think for carlos you
know he's starting to
to understand his daughters and they're
at a pivotal age in their lives and
i think just
getting closer to them and and really
supporting them understanding what they
like what they're about uh these little
human beings you know where do you want
to see lorena go in a season two
ooh
that is such a good question i would
hope that like she doesn't lose her
dramatics
and she figures out her work-life
balance that's so hard for so many women
especially women in media and digital
and you know that are faces of a network
or or a company so i hope that like that
struggle becomes a little bit less
and still hilarious getting there but
you know and more paul more paul cutie
pie oh what what a dreamboat i want to
continue uh representing my community in
the best way i want to tell people that
it is possible that there is a way and
i just want you to know that be
different it's okay
i
think for season two uh
george needs to lose some of his power i
don't want to say anything more than
that but i think george is pretty on top
for season one and i think it'd be
really interesting direction to go where
uh maybe george isn't so much on top
with things maybe some humble pie humble
flan humble flood
i cannot believe it's been 18 years
since we saw you of course on the
brothers garcia now here we are in 2022
the birth of the garcias how did this
all happen
not overnight but um but i'm definitely
glad that it did because uh you know the
original show was
was
probably one of my favorite experiences
as a young child actor to be able to get
the opportunity to relive it and meet
new cast members and have a wife and two
girls now you know when i found out that
i have a wife and kids i was so stoked
you know like it's
a difference from my actual real life so
um it's just great it was crazy because
i was just concerned about you know the
show coming back the show coming back
and then when we were actually going to
do it i had to be like
okay so who is george again because
george's life has has taken you know
various turns that mine haven't um i i'm
not a father i'm not a husband i am not
a tech mobile um so i i i
i'm doing all right but i don't have a
mansion in mexico uh so i had to figure
that out as soon as i was in the
auditions with with nicia i was like
okay that's that's definitely my wife
when i got down there i was like okay i
feel really so i will feel really
supportive of nietzsche i want to be
able to to help her out and everything
that she needs and as soon as i met you
know maeve who plays my daughter
victoria i was like okay i'm very
protective of her nobody hurt her and
i'm gonna make sure that everything that
like she has everything that she needs
and then as far as being rich i i just
had to step into the mansion and then
just be like yeah this is my place
welcome everyone to my home but don't
touch anything you as a newscaster i
mean you literally had me crying tears
of laughter it was it was just hilarious
seeing you go toe-to-toe with um how do
we describe your colleague not not a
great my arch nemesis you're arch
nemesis jeremy who plays my my photo
arch nemesis is literally one of the
nicest people in the world and so when
we were like both on set he'd be like
god i'm so mean to you like i feel gross
i was like but you're nailing it dude
and like what's really special is he
played a character from the original
show um as did my husband paul rodriguez
on the show we were trying to cast my
husband i was like um paul rodriguez jr
cutie pie why are we not like
entertaining this and so um jeff made
the call and lo and behold they were
like congrats you got paul rodriguez jr
and he he's been he was just wonderful
and lovely and you know oliver who plays
my son max um was a big fan of paul so
like to watch him be a little like star
struck was just the like the cutest this
is my first opportunity in the american
television so it's my first show
in english so i was terrified at the
beginning and bobby thank you so much
and bobby was the one who said since
like day one like we got this don't
worry you can do it and i remember when
we were about to shoot the first scene
uh we were rehearsing and he made me
feel so comfortable like okay we can run
lines and we can do this and that and
that's something that it's really nice
because you can really see the love on
screen and that's why we really have
this love off screen elsa what a
wonderful addition you've been to the
show what was it like joining this big
happy family before i had met everyone
it was definitely a little bit
intimidating because i was like oh this
show like people love it and it's like
i've been historic and oh my god i'm so
nervous but then as soon as i met them
like it was just so easy their family
they're so welcoming and then the kids
on set there's something about kids
being on set
you just feel good you know so it was
great i can assume that you guys feel
like you hit the lotto with trinity i
mean what a fantastic actress you are
trinity and i think it's it's wild that
the show the brothers garcia it was
airing before you were even born
so did what did you do to prepare did
you go back into the archives and watch
old episodes yeah i mean definitely
like before there's been questions like
oh did he watch the brothers garcia and
i was like that's before my time
uh i did definitely go back and watch
some clips and of course love the show
yeah was finding a vcr player huh
[Music]
you